i'm gonna jump into spoilers now and i i
have some questions um so uh i love the
face off joke in the movie just [ __ ]
love i wanna know um uh could you talk
about how that joke came about
really wish we could have thrown uh some
headphones on walker in an action scene
with some louis armstrong
playing and a single white dove arcing
across the screen john wu style
um
the faceoff thing was just a totally
random uh i think kate um warhoff who uh
runs uh b for effort which is my wife's
production company uh with my wife uh
gave that to me as a christmas present
and i thought it was awesome and we were
happy to be shooting the adam project uh
over that period and so i called sean or
i sent a photo i think i sent a photo of
it to you sean yeah so we got to put
this in and i know just the spot and
next thing you know we were rewriting
mark's scene together and we added this
little piece about it and
that's another example right of what i
was saying what people don't know tiny
little random instinctive weird [ __ ]
ideas
they pop up all the time and on our
movies we'll follow those leads and they
end up taking a kind of lecture hall
university scene and giving it like this
weird little kind of moment that is
idiosyncratic and for us makes the
character more interesting makes the
scene more interesting and those are the
kinds of random little ideas that you
stumble on along the way that will
always follow those leads
speaking of the uh the bar scene um it's
like everybody else it's one of my
favorite scenes in the movie for
multiple reasons i love jen's what jen
says kids are assassins of happiness and
ryan you say you know boys always come
back for their mamas and you can see
like you can just feel the emotion
between these two characters ryan i know
this scene was very important to you i
know this movie is very personal to you
can you sort of talk about uh working
specifically on that scene and because
the audience feels so much emotion
looking at your face looking at jen's
face and what you guys are saying well
you know i i mean sean can speak to the
macro of it but i
yeah look it's to me it's the ultimate
wish fulfillment scene it's the moment
where you get to sit across from a
parent as a peer you know there's always
that moment that you never want to rob
any child of which is that that moment
where your parent you know becomes a
person
you know and there's something there's
something very magical about that also
there's something very emotional about
that so so to me it was uh you know
these are all things that are very real
to me my dad uh was difficult man he was
not an easy guy to to know really i mean
less about him being a difficult
personality but more he's a really
difficult man to know um and you know
that is all in this movie and and um you
know and and the idea that um
you know that we tell ourselves kind of
stories about parents or stories about
people to sort of adjust to the
narrative we have about ourselves uh or
to explain the narrative we have about
ourselves and that narrative isn't
always true the story that we tell
ourselves isn't always true and i like
that that that that happens but you know
that the line you know boys always come
back for their mamas is a real line
that's the real thing that's that's
something that we said to my mom my
brothers and i when my dad died and you
know we showed up for her and you know
it's something we always say in our
house too we show up you know i said to
my kids what do we do and my kids will
say we show up you know and it means
that you go you show up for people like
sometimes it's not convenient or [ __ ]
perfect or anything if you show up for
people in life they're going to show up
for you and everything everything about
your life is going to be better with
that kind of integrity so um that was
that was a big part of my story i think
that was in in this in that in that bar
scene which is one of my favorite scenes
in the film for sure sean if you don't
mind i want to actually talk to you
about directing the scene because i love
the way you shot it the it starts out
where the camera is static and then um
as ryan says aren't you grieving it
starts zooming in slowly and as you're
cutting back and forth you're zooming in
closer and closer until finally at the
end you know you have
two relatively close-ups but they're not
fully close up but i love the way you
directed the scene can you sort of talk
about how you figured out speaking
earlier in the interview where you're
like how do you how do you shoot
something there's a million ways to
shoot it talk a little bit about how you
decided to shoot it like that it is all
just how i want it to feel and so at
first she doesn't know this stranger he
can't believe his mother is sitting down
the bar from him there's a little bit of
wariness i have the camera stay put and
keep its distance but as he
as these two characters reveal
themselves to each other and as there's
emotional connection they're getting
emotionally closer so i want to get
emotionally closer to that character too
to that actor so uh just for the true
film wonks watching this steve i'm just
going to correct you they were dahlians
not zoom
big
come on
i know listen
i'm like an amateur doing this job
eventually
somewhere people like sean leaving you
zooms what is he like is it a 7d robert
altman
yeah
but literally i just that was what so i
just i wanted to get more intimate with
the characters as they got more intimate
with each other so i literally moved the
camera on both sides through space to
get spatially more intimate with them
and i didn't even think about it in
those terms that's much more academic
in my wording than i would ever think on
set but that's just what it felt like
and so that's how i wanted it to to feel
visually too
zoey is uh fantastic in the movie and i
love her introduction she comes into
some badass music
she kicks a tremendous amount of ass
i love the scene so much uh can you sort
of talk about how you guys decided that
was gonna be the introduction to the
character and how you picked the song i
feel like we're gonna go back to that
same theme of people don't realize how
random little moments can be movie
defining ryan and i like on free guy um
you know the rhythm of our
post-production is we'll shoot i'll
spend a little time kind of getting it
into shape with my editor of you know 15
16 years and then ryan comes and
basically we live together in the edit
room
um
every day long days fun days and we go
through every single cut in the movie so
we're up to that scene and we're like
ryan had this idea early on actually in
the opening scene in the movies like i
think music
our goal all along was to make us not a
sci-fi movie an adventure movie a
wishful filming movie so we wanted music
to tell the audience
permission to have fun
permission to not take it super
seriously so music and needle drops
which are a huge part of ryan's over in
general um became important so that
you're telling the audience okay to have
fun we're watching that backyard scene
and we're just playing songs from our
iphones
and i remember i was just scrolling
through like this is led zeppelin on
spotify
and
i came to good times bad times i hit
play i said to the editor hit play on
the picture so it's just the tinny music
coming from my phone picture on the
screen we're like
oh my gosh this is holy [ __ ] and we just
all felt it in real time just off the
iphone then it became the saga of
getting led zeppelin's permission um and
netflix permission to spend what it
costs to get a led zeppelin song but it
all worked out and
it makes for i agree a truly badass
entrance for her character
yeah sometimes but also like that
there's this the song in the in the bar
is a matte burning her song called let
it be which is just like a random i just
had listened to it that day i think the
song had just come out like the day
before and it just spoke to me so much
about who this character was a guy who's
like really struggling to let things go
like just cannot let things go despite
knowing he should let it go and wanting
to let it go um and it was just like the
seat the sean laid it in perfect and it
just worked it never we never changed it
i think that was from the day we shot
that scene was when we laid that song in
basically and it just stayed forever so
music is you know
it's either right or it isn't you just
know kind of right away
an another scene that i think is so good
is uh
zoe and these are very specific things
but like when basically when zoe is
killed uh by her um her reaction on her
face
is so [ __ ] good because you are
seeing everything play
out on her face and then you also have
ryan to commend you when you're driving
away your emotion in the truck like
these are really great performances can
can you sean can you sort of talk about
i just i i there's
i am so uh loving you right now because
you've just
flagged two of my absolute favorite
moments in the movie
where you you know we all know like ryan
reynolds he's been famous a long time um
but man i on that scene i mounted the
camera to the truck and i said ryan
drive away you're driving away from the
only woman you've ever left and he just
brought it and it's in the kind of scene
that we don't see ryan do every day and
it felt special and it felt raw and the
same thing zoe is staring down her own
death
and there's not a line of dialogue and
she plays 17 different emotions as the
camera slowly pushes in it's one of
ryan's my favorite moments too and i
just i have to tell you
um i feel really lucky that this movie
has a lot of famous people in it but
they're not doing just the things you
expect zoe saldana jennifer garner
ruffalo ryan reynolds these are great
performances and they're performances
that have a different level of nuance
and dramatic content
than we're necessarily used to seeing in
some of their movies and i feel like the
lucky guy who get who got to have those
moments in in my movie i'm really
grateful you're right can you talk a
little bit about filming that scene
because you're and also looking at zoe's
performance if you don't mind sharing
mm-hmm uh well zoe look
it's not often that you get to work with
with people who's whose work you're very
familiar with but then they get to work
in a movie that
you're in and a part of making and they
are revelatory i mean i said that to
zoey and i said that to jen you know who
both have these just intense emotional
scenes
you know in in the middle of this film
that
i i feel like we're seeing colors or
sides of them that we've never seen
before and and that's always really
special to me that's always what i feel
like we've done something really great
is that you're you feel like you're
seeing somebody you know very well but
they're they are also a revelation and
um in terms of the driving a waste i
mean i you know to me that scene is all
about a guy who is you know as
irresponsible and as impetuous as any
human being on earth because he's
willing to completely unravel and husk
[ __ ] the space-time continuum uh because
he wants to be with his wife uh he is
willing to do he's willing to basically
just destroy the fabric of the universe
to be with his wife that does not make
him a hero that makes him just the
genuinely the the world's most
irresponsible human being so i think in
in that moment he's kind of feeling the
weight of this you know this moment that
like i came
back
for this person who is so much smarter
than me and she understands the the the
significance and the gravity of what
what we've done here and uh and i'm all
of that was for naught i'm about to lose
her anyway and i think that's just a
moment of pure rage uh at himself at
myself in that moment so yeah
uh another i'm almost out of time which
i can't believe but another scene i
wanted to talk about is uh uh
there's this great bit where um
uh
young adam is reacting to ryan to your
body and asking if he's going to get
laid and like basically it's just really
funny and it's also like just true
because you know you've just been told
that time travel exists you don't care
about that you just want to know if
you're going to get a girl you know um
yeah these are the kinds of lines that i
you know i laughed a lot because i i
it
resonates so can you sort of talk about
how much was that like again is that
improv is that stuff that ryan you're
doing in advance is that in the original
script i'm just curious where some of
these lines come from well i honestly
have no i yeah i don't know i remember
more than ryan ryan never remembers what
he wrote what he uh here's the way free
guy work is the same way adam project
worked we had a very solid script and
then ryan and i came aboard and we saw
the movie that we wanted to make and
then we take the script and we do a pass
at just polishing up mostly dialogue
so that the script is hitting the stuff
that we want so before we shot adam
project it already had a healthy dose of
our writing on top of and in
collaboration with jonathan tropper's
writing so yes a lot of that
dialogue was baked in before we shot but
there was there's one moment that i
remember was ryan and and the only other
person i've ever seen do this
at this level was tina fey she's really
good at writing improv dialogue that is
making fun of herself and there's a
moment where ryan said to the kid
because ryan's there in a tank top and
whatever um
and he ryan has the kid go um so when
does all this happen and does everyone
skip leg day in the future
and you know
it's literally ryan acknowledging that
his legs are not quite as beepy as his
shoulders and the rest of his upper
torso that is on camera
it's ryan writing mockery about his own
body and shoving it into the mouth of a
young boy
[Laughter]
yes it is an honor a distinctive honor
by the way steve if you do struggle for
a headline i just want to make this
super easy for you ryan reynolds husk
[ __ ] the space time continuum
that will not be that will not be the
headline but i appreciate you the
suggestion something about that you know
um although that's really funny uh i
listen before i run out of time though i
do want to talk about the ending how did
you guys always have everyone playing
catch
and um you know with uh uh
mark saying to ryan you know i love you
i'm really proud of you like there's a
lot of emotional beats at the end and
i'm just curious um how that came about
and was it ever something else
it was never something else
but i
i knew i wanted to not shy away from
that catharsis at the end i like movies
that make me feel a lot um
and i just again i felt lucky that i had
my guy my you know now one of my
greatest friends in my life in ryan and
we're making a movie that is a blast and
action and funny but also gets to be a
drama in some moments where it counts
that felt
like it just felt thrilling to me it
still feels thrilling to me and so that
ending was always built in that there
was gonna be a goodbye we were never
gonna give it a happy ending
but we had to give it an ending with
closure and redemption
and uh and so we did a little rewrite on
it but then we shot that scene
we started rehearsing it steve and
literally after less than a full
rehearsal i felt oh it's it's happening
it's coming so let's just no more
rehearse we shoot and mark from take one
brought it ryan i remember ryan saying
like i just needed to listen i just
locked into them all i had to do
literally is just look at mark and and
feel everything every unrequited moment
i've ever had with my my own father in
real life and you know and and truly
like that was that i felt so lucky to be
working with someone like mark ruffalo
who you know is as good if not better
than everyone already knows him to be um
it was it was pretty and then the catch
stuff is that's all for me is incredibly
resonant that's
that is how i connected with my father
that is when i my father who's now been
dead for you know six or seven years i
all of my memories that are that are
beautiful with with my father are us
having a catch on the lawn and it and
that is in the movie but that's also
true of my real life my dad always had
time for that um even though we all we
didn't see eye to eye on just about
everything
we always had time for that and and so
there's something very powerful and
moving about us getting into that place
after we have this incredible healing
moment between all of us the three of us
really uh that we end up you know on the
lawn having a catch you know but i just
think there's something so magical about
and such wish fulfillment about me i
would love
i would kill i would do anything
to have a catch with my old man when
he's my age or around that time right
now like to be out on a lawn and throw a
ball with him just for a few minutes and
just sort of see him as the
three-dimensional person that he
actually is instead of this mythologized
either super villain or superhero that
that you know we we tend to create in
our minds to make everything else make
sense
yeah it's also one of the reasons why
the film hit me and i think it will hit
a lot of people is that i while watching
this i was thinking about my father who
has also passed in terms of meeting him
at a younger age and knowing who he was
because you know i only you know what i
mean we all see our parents for what
they are but not as the humans they are
and you know now that we're all getting
older and we are you know
it's just you know it's it's um it's
beautiful in the way that the wish
fulfillment and i think every person can
relate to it
yeah
well certainly a big part of why we
wanted to make this movie and why we
feel really lucky that we did
yeah um i could ask you guys a million
other questions um but i think that uh
the publicist on this thing will [ __ ]
kill me if i go any longer here's the
good news frosty we're gonna make so
many more movies together you're going
to get more bites